cardinals take the field
and carlos martinez going tonight for st
louis
and it's been a while since he was a
starter pitching against the chicago
cubs
carlos martinez ready to work
face jack peterson
and the first pitch is drilled into the
air out towards right center field
that's well struck on its way and gone
jack peterson a lead off homer first
pitch of the game his second of the year
and the cubs jump out one-nothing mr
mustache with the home run
we were just talking uh a some time ago
before we
came on air about jack peterson and how
hard he's been hitting the ball
but he hasn't been getting any lift it's
been a lot of line drives a lot of
hard ground balls and sooner or later
you knew the power is going to come
because that's what he has done
throughout his big league career and it
comes on the very first pitch
of the game a two-seam barrel finder
from carlos martinez
and jack peterson puts the cubs up one
pitcher kyle hendricks ready to go to
work
cardinals are really high on this fine
young prospect
there's a swing and a miss goes upstairs
struck him out
kyle got that pitch you know the swing
and miss on that earlier in the at-bat
and he said all right if you're going to
attack it up there i'm not going to
worry about trying to freeze you i'm
going to throw it up above the barrel
ball's running back just can't get to it
when it's up above the belt like that
edmundo
sosa batting 250
slowly hit tough play bare-handed throw
it away
sos on his way to second base
single and an error by david bode i
wasn't sure he didn't because of that
stumble i thought he actually fouled the
ball off of his foot but here it is
and apparently not off of his foot
although maybe the
cubs think that it was and there's the
bare-handed throw and it was just a wild
throw way wide of
rizzo who had no chance to make that
play hunter at second
let me go to the top of the order for
tommy edmond
edmond with a fly ball and shallow
center horner going out
half coming in it drops and the game is
tied
edmond to second base it hung up there
forever
and the cardinals have tied it 1-1
before you take any gifts you are given
and the
cardinals have been given two of them in
this inning this should be an out
this is in the air too long notice tommy
edmond running the ball
out from the very beginning and half i
think he thought horner was going to
make that play
but it was closer to him than it was to
horner
and he finally kind of gets close to the
ball probably could have caught it
anyway but
goes as a double as it should and the
cardinals tie it
so it's now david bodie grounded back to
martinez over one rizzo hit by a pitch
baez walked hit by a pitch and they're
all loaded up and this being done with
two outs
and the 1-0
edmond stays with it and makes the play
bottom of inning number four paul
goldschmidt lined out to left his first
time
as goldschmidt rips that one to center
half his back
back some more leaps and makes the grab
tracking it tracking it and ultimately
catching it
[Applause]
and on third one away here in the top
half of the fifth inning bondo strikes
to jock
in the air that one blasted out towards
center
going back is bader there to make the
catch
and tagging from third coming in to
score nicole
horner jack peterson has knocked in both
runs tonight the cubs leader it's 2-1
so one out two runners on let's see if
bodhi can do some damage here with two
men on
2-2 pitch to david body put
[Applause]
we go to the bottom of the sixth inning
cardinals bad
cubs lead two to one
two down bags loaded for harrison bader
on the ground softly hit baez throws him
out and that
is the inning now a corner in scoring
position at second in a tie game in the
seventh inning
in the dirt and it gets past molina
racing for third
throw goes into left get up
and here he comes horner coming in and
he'll score
willie harris said call nico 3-2
on a pitch that got past molina and then
an error on the catcher
as chris bryant steps in and the one-two
bryant drives one in the air to right
center field might be a gapper that ball
is going to be back
bouncing off the wall in deep right
center field peterson racing around
third heading home
he will score and the clubs lead four to
two
comes in great position now they get out
of that jam in the bottom of the six
hendricks does his thing and now the
offense responds with a little help from
the cardinals
talked all year long about chris bryant
being able to handle the fastball here's
a little 99
[Applause]
dylan carlson is up edmond the runner at
first
sosa is the runner at third carlson
base heading to right a run will score
edmond to third
and here comes goldie it's a one run
game
two outs nance swinging a grounder to
third
body to second and they get out of it
with a one-run lead
and silgaard against webb with the bases
loaded the infield drawn in
that one whacked into left field that's
a base hit williams will pick it up
fire it in a run comes in to score
sogard in rbi
single and it's 5-3
off the inside edge he walked him and
that'll force in a run
payoff pitch and he walked him and
another run will come in and it's 7-3
well this cardinal pen kind of lived up
to the billing in terms of
the walks being at issue
that's hit hard fair ball down the first
baseline it'll hit off the sidewall
sogart into score bryant comes around
stopping at third as contreras now he's
racing home throw tag
out
that one line and a base hit out into
left center field
and in the score is rizzo buy as an rbi
knock and it is 10-3
what a night for the cubs
[Applause]
hit hard and that's a fair ball past
arenado
that's off the sidewall baez is in
behind him is half throw to second tag
and out
and bodhi cut down at second base but
two more come in
and the cubs break things open